>>Narrator: Movement in
art integrate with learning
at the John Moore School
in Sacramento, California,
one of the first Waldorf-inspired
public schools.
>>Cheryl: Running through the
mud, digging with their shovels,
and singing to the teacher and
really speak to Waldorf Education.
It's always about stimulating
the creativity
and imagination of the child.
What Waldorf methods are,
essentially, is an integration
of the arts into regular
curricular areas.
>>Izabelle: With one, like sometimes
we draw pictures, when we're done
with this, she puts
a letter inside some,
and we try to figure out the letter.
>>Teacher: These are
first-grade main lesson books.
Where the princess was
surrounded by faeries,
the faeries that surround the
princes turned into the letter F.
And in this way, the
children's imagination is woken
up to the entire world.
>>Barbara: We have apples that we
cut in half to find five seeds.
We traced our hands
with five fingers.
We saw the five-pointed stars,
so that we had science integrated
with nature studies, and geometry
and artistic work before
it ever led to mathematics.
>>Students: Five!
>>Teacher: Good.
Who wants to do the backwards one?
Severin? Here it comes.
>>Students: Ten!
>>Teacher: Good work, first grade!
Who wants to...
>>Narrator: Kids move to
learn math, and social skills.
>>Vince: They were
skipping through the room,
following each other
around in a chain.
It's developing spatial awareness
of what's happening in the room,
and how they're working as a group.
>>Taylor: I like the
John Moore School,
how you get to play instruments,
you get to do hand work,
movement classes, you get to
do all sorts of extra stuff
as the schools is going
to allow you to do.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to edutopia.org.